cette machine est une véritable
innovation en matière de recyclage des
déchets alimentaires
conçu en région parisienne elle est
entièrement fabriqué dans cette
entreprise dumas kfw elle permet grâce à
des termes aux bactéries de réduire de
90 à 95 % le volume des biodéchets
l'innovation c'est de réduire les
déchets alimentaires en une en 24 heures
en
pour obtenir une poudre qui sera
utilisable comme
amendement au bout d'une semaine utilisé
à tout de suite c'est un herbicide au
bout d'une semaine à quinze jours
c'est un engrais utilisable pour pour
les jardins pour les espaces verts et
c'est une entreprise bourguignonne qui
est chargé de la conception de cet
appareil destiné aux chaînes de
restauration et aux collectivités un
marché qui est amenée à se développer
rapidement
on a une quinzaine de machines à notre
effectif sur l'année 2020 mais par
contre en un prévisionnel qui commence à
monter aux alentours de 70 machines pour
la nuit les années 2000 21 selon le
volume traité chaque machine vote entre
15000 et 30000 euros pour les
professionnels mais un modèle pour les
particuliers pourrait voir le jour dans
les mois à venir pour un coût beaucoup
plus bas